how do you stay motivated on YouTube
when growth is slow don't compare your
growth to others are you actually doing
better on YouTube than you realize you
gotta stop overthinking and start
working sitting idle makes you prone to
negative thoughts what is your motive
for starting YouTube in the first place
maybe you're feeling discouraged
frustrated and even tired from just not
breaking through yet
in this episode of the think media
podcast I want to share five tips for
staying motivated and recapturing your
inspiration but the first thing I want
to encourage you with is you're not
alone anybody who's taken the leap of
faith to start posting content on
YouTube to doing the hard work of
sacrificing your time and putting in
energy and learning new skills and
getting uncomfortable has experienced
emotions of discouragement
overwhelm negative thinking patterns
it's a whole thing when you start
creating YouTube content so I want you
to remember that although this can feel
lonely and can feel isolating that
you're in good company with other
creators who are fighting the fight of
getting views just like you are but you
haven't broken through yet or you just
feel like maybe you've plateaued or that
growth has been slow and maybe even
you've been doing this a couple years
well I do believe that these five things
things will really help you when it
comes to staying motivated and even
breaking through into the growth you are
looking for and number one is don't
compare your growth to others man
comparison is the thief of joy and the
killer of creativity and absolutely the
destroyer of motivation you know
comparison is the fastest way to
stirring up the pot of anxiety failure
feelings of inadequacy and so I want to
encourage you number one it's your race
your pace I think that one of the
reasons why it can be demotivating is
yes you maybe want to give your boss
notice that you're going to part-time or
completely be able to quit your job to
do that and that's a lot of the YouTube
creators aspirations and if you're a
business owner you may be feeling like
man I'm having a little bit of growth on
YouTube and some leads are coming in
like some growth is happening but it's
just like really not enough and maybe
your P L's looking in a little tight
right now it's a little tough and you
look over to somebody else who started
after you did and they blew up and you
get on Instagram you look at somebody
else they just posted their silver play
button you you know look at other
channels and your same Niche that you
even try to really objectively study
their content and you're like I feel
like my content's better and my
Productions better and comparison just
leads you down a path that is ultimately
not helpful don't compare your growth to
others that's not going to help you stay
motivated it's going to suck away your
motivation I also want you to remember
that there's difference in niches and
topics you know that sometimes it's
absolutely the wrong thing to compare a
niche business channel to a
entertainment YouTube channel and I want
you to remember that different niches
and different topics
experience different levels of growth a
niche business Channel may never
experience massive growth but it may be
more than sufficient to actually reach
the target audience that they want to
reach to reach the revenue goals that
they want to reach compared to kind of
traditional YouTube success metrics
which is oh a million subscribers and
millions of views and viral videos
there's just differences so be aware of
not comparing your topic to some other
industry even the size of your Niche
there's a lot of reasons why even think
media is the size it is but might not be
as large as other things because we
specifically talk about tools for
creators cameras and audio tools for
making videos and video podcasts versus
consumer electronics at large now that's
not to say our channel would be bigger
or smaller but just when for example CES
the Consumer Electronics Show here in
Vegas a lot more people are buying TVs
for their home and sound systems and
cell phones than are buying cameras it
is a small demographic that wants to buy
a camera to create YouTube content so it
would be foolish for me to compare my
channel to an industry that is a hundred
times larger than mine bottom line
comparison is not going to be that
helpful right and also your starting
point could be different so sometimes
you go oh somebody else started after me
but they're further than me but you're
like yeah but they also did an
internship for 10 years at a media
Department of a church or they have some
experience it doesn't even really matter
but these are just factors of why you're
it's not all the same it's your race
it's your situation it's your
circumstances and ultimately you got to
do the best with what you have and not
worry about comparing yourself and
especially your growth to other people
number two though I think the
opportunity to get motivated again
especially if you've been grinding for
the long haul for that YouTube
breakthrough is I want to encourage you
to reframe your perspective number two
reframe your perspective I'm reading a
book called decisive about how to make
better decisions and one of the key
tactics they recommend for making better
decisions is attain distance before
deciding it means oftentimes we're too
close to the problem we're too close
we're too emotionally tied up with the
thing that is discouraging us or
frustrating us and the goal is to take a
step back and get a wider perspective to
get away from a narrow perspective of
the situation so I want to ask you a
question are you actually doing better
on YouTube than you realize
could it be that actually the growth is
not as slow as you imagine and here's
what I mean I've actually learned from
now coaching people through Channel
reviews in particular through our video
ranking Academy program through our
monthly q and A's inside of our private
Facebook group and people ask me
questions a lot and I hear this a lot a
lot of discouragement or a lot of I wish
I was growing faster or I'm not growing
this is my favorite one people say Sean
I'm not growing Sean my channel is
plateaued Sean I'm completely stuck Sean
what's wrong with my channel it appears
to be broken so I go to their Channel
I've got the vid IQ Vision plugin
installed I go to just the stats page
that tells me how many views they're
getting how many subscribers they're
getting how many videos they've uploaded
and it's either green because they've
experienced growth in the last 28 days
or it's red and in either case I'll go
to the channel of the person who says
Sean I'm not growing and I'll see that
they got 23 4 23 400 136 views in the
last 28 days and their channels views
are up 200 percent that they got 87 new
subscribers and that percentage there is
27 positive growth over the month
previous and that they uploaded eight
videos two a week so I'm like okay
I know that this isn't viral compared to
the most famous YouTubers but if you
actually reframe your perspective is
your channel actually growing though
because if you're making forward
progress then it just might not be as
fast as you want but you could be being
overly critical on the progress that
you're making if you also could multiply
the progress you're making or perhaps
figure out let's say how to monetize the
community that you already have as
opposed to reaching anybody new then
it's a matter of reframing your
perspective and if I objectively on the
think media podcast think back to how
often this happens I would argue that 7
out of 10 people have an over overly
negative point of view of the positive
things that are happening on their
YouTube channel so I want to encourage
you to perhaps just take a step back and
look at your channel and actually say
actually even in this I feel like I feel
like a failure but yet if I objectively
measured my YouTube Channel's growth in
the last month it's all positive I feel
like a failure but if I thought
okay I only reached 83 000 views on my
YouTube channel in the last month and I
applied that to the fact I grew up in a
small town Like Me Maybe you grew up
small town kid College Dropout I grew up
on six acres on a farm with goats and my
horse little and ultimately this was not
a big area Arlington Washington
especially at the time and so I start
getting 25 000 views on my YouTube
channel it's like twice the size of the
town I grew up and I know that if you're
trying to make YouTube ad Revenue you're
like yeah but Sean I need millions of
views And subscribe to the podcast we
have content on all of that but let's
just reframe our perspective think about
the opportunity that you have uploading
videos on this platform that is giving
you views and that is helping you reach
people and yes I know you gotta invest
in gear and you probably also enjoy that
like me so you've got a gear problem and
you order gear you don't even
necessarily need but you know you you're
building out the battle station you're
buying the cameras and you're thinking
about the economics you're thinking
about the emotions and the Judgment you
have from friends and family because
you're spending more than your making on
YouTube however honor the progress
you're making reframe
the results you're getting
and then also just take the next step
because once we reframe our perspective
I found that another wave of motivation
comes in like oh shoot
wait I'm up 200 since last month and
what if I could keep that going because
then multiply that out eventually it
becomes incredibly hard you know like
early on in your business every time
sometimes people like advertise their
product or their program they're like
this doubled my Revenue well it's one
thing to double your Revenue when you
make five dollars a month because you're
like dude I doubled my Revenue I made
ten dollars you know but it's all
another thing if you make a million
dollars a year and you're like I doubled
my Revenue like a whole nother million
dollars it's a little bit different than
an extra five punch line is ultimately
if you can just maintain the growth and
one of the things we say in our video
ranking Academy program is go for green
now I use the vid IQ Vision plugin so I
can look at your channel even if without
your permission to just see the external
stats of your channel but all of us have
the ability to just go into our YouTube
analytics and on that home page and as
you're probably all too familiar with
the encouraging or discouraging
information but it either is red gray or
green it's either like views were lower
than it was last month views were about
the same as it was last month or views
were up 23 over last month YouTube is
really about beating your previous best
so number one don't compare yourself to
others compare yourself to who you were
yesterday compare your channel to who
you were yesterday and please frame some
Grace around that because talk about the
most stressful place on planet Earth is
your YouTube analytics because there's
some things you're like oh man
everything's down it's like dude it's
summer relax like your topic isn't even
popular right now it'll come back when
it's back to school like there's just
different seasons if we can just compare
ourselves if we can beat our previous
best and reframe our perspective and the
final thing on number two is even let's
redefine growth because I know you're
like Sean I want subs Sean I want views
but you know there's a lot of other ways
to measure growth like let's do a quick
assessment of your time on YouTube over
the last few weeks months or years let
me ask you a question and just be honest
and please be kind to yourself have you
learned new skills are there skills now
that you have developed because you
started creating YouTube content and
building a channel that you did not know
before you started have you taken the
time to honor and celebrate the skills
that you've learned maybe you haven't
fully seen the results of those skills
yet but you're still in a growth you're
in a personal growth season learning the
skill of content creation communication
video editing distribution online
marketing
have you grown in your understanding of
the platforms or experienced growth
across other platforms maybe you're
posting vertical content on multiple
platforms and so you can celebrate the
wins at different places YouTube pays
the best it's the best home base you
might be like whoa I got a viral Tick
Tock what did that mean financially
nothing and it's probably going to get
shut down but nevertheless celebrating
the wins have you gained new knowledge
I would argue if you're listening to the
think media podcast you're probably the
most educated person at every party you
attend when it comes to YouTube
marketing YouTube content creation
online marketing now you might be
hanging out with people who don't care
but you know you're like I wish I could
geek out and talk about this with people
but like people with my family and
friends like they don't want to talk
about it nevertheless like think about
the knowledge you've been gaining like
you've been growing I would guess and
even that growth may feel slow I think
that one of the mistakes we make is we
don't honor the progress we're making
have you made any new connections and
relationships have you made one friend
no this might not be like the deepest
relationship it's an internet friend but
have you made any internet friends have
you have you met somebody like is your
life now richer because you know
somebody you've had you found some new
people to follow and by following those
people inspiration has come your way
education has come your way maybe there
is somebody that you send reels back and
forth to on Instagram and people that
maybe I know people in our VRA Community
have made friendships and connections
inside of our private Facebook group
these are all things if those weren't
there before like man since stepping out
on this journey I've learned new skills
I've gained new knowledge I've
transformed as a person I've made new
connections and relationships an
important term for reframing your
perspective is viral versus viral for me
our friend Brock Johnson who's been on
the podcast originally shared this term
with me and I loved it it was vfm and it
was the difference between viral versus
viral for me so it makes me think you
know oh these days if I don't get 100
million views like Mr Beast it doesn't
even matter and I didn't go viral okay I
mean maybe by gundam style definition of
viral a billion views Crazy Charlie bit
my finger for any buddy who's you know
aware of the old school yeah that's
maybe viral videos but viral for me is
if you're getting 30 views 300 views and
you pop out a video that gets 3 000 or
13 000 that's a viral for me video it's
also a significant video because you
need to celebrate I wouldn't even call
them small wins the reason they're small
is because you're number one comparing
yourself 13 000 views is freaking nuts
you know like you get a short that gets
27 000 views and yet you still go to bed
sad we gotta reframe the whole game we
have to rewire our brains I want to just
encourage you I hope after this podcast
that you just take a step away from
negative self-talk and you step into a
positive perspective of the growth
you've been experiencing are you ready
to start or grow your YouTube channel do
you feel stuck and need help connecting
the dots join this free web class where
you'll learn the step-by-step playbook
for YouTube success we've helped
thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs just like you grow their
influence with video register today for
this exclusive training at
thinkmasterclass.com and chances are
friend there's a lot more bright spots
and a lot more growth in your channel
and in your history and in your
knowledge and in your community that
maybe you just kind of have forgotten
about haven't acknowledged and when you
start to acknowledge it your motivation
will increase number three how do I stay
motivated when I want to quit how do I
stay motivated on YouTube when growth is
slow you got to stop overthinking and
start working sitting idle makes you
prone to negative thoughts and if you're
like me you are one of your greatest
skills is overthinking giving given some
alone time does this person like me or
not why did I get that negative comment
why I thought that video was going to do
good why didn't the video do good is a
meteorite going to hit the world and
destroy it man is our country about to
be so divided that it's never you know
you just start spiraling uh like what
was that that comment that that team
ever made or my spouse made like that
was kind of mean did they really mean
that is that person thinking about me
right now why do I suck why is
everything just sitting idle
can lead to a lot of overthinking and
not a lot of progress and because when
you're sitting idle your mind can just
wander and go a lot of different ways
well what are some of the ways to just
reverse that is literally to just start
working now I know this is hard because
you're like well I don't have the
motivation like just start like start
moving start working you know set some
new goals set some small goals set some
realistic goals and set some action
goals not some results goals and this is
a big key I think for motivation if
you're measuring just by results then
you might be criticizing yourself
because you're like I don't have a
silver play button yet which is insane
by the way a hundred thousand
subscribers what are we even talking
about you can have a very profitable
successful Channel you're proud of
without ever getting a silver play
button we have so many success students
that don't have silver play buttons but
that are full-time that's a big
opportunity the big key is how do we
define success and if you only set goals
that are like my goal is 1 000
subscribers in the next 30 days
I think that's good but that's not my
favorite kind of goal my favorite kind
of goal is an action goal my goal is two
uploads a week for the next 30 days and
then when you do it you celebrate you're
like honey get the kids we're going to
Chick-fil-A I'm grabbing that Polynesian
sauce I need some of that buffalo sauce
give me a little uh some ranch as well I
need some waffle fries I just hit my
goals what was the goal
eight uploads in a month did you grow no
the channel shrunk you know what I mean
like maybe the results weren't what you
thought but you could be proud of the
actions I I want to learn a particular
skill set so I've created a reading list
you have a PDP a personal development
plan because you want to grow because
part of this whole thing is learning new
things so you on your PDP is I want to
read one book a month that will increase
my education as it relates to how to be
a successful content creator a
successful content creator
um as a career or somebody that uses
video marketing to grow my business so
I'm studying online marketing video
marketing communication storytelling
whatever so you pick out a list of books
you put 12 books on the list you read
one a month
and you when you accomplish it you
celebrate the action the truth is
nothing really changed if you read a
book and maybe for you that's audiobook
but it's something to celebrate the
actions of man my thumbnails are getting
better my goal this month is to simplify
my thumbnails so like action goals stop
overthinking and start working like just
get to work start taking action even
getting out of planning a little bit
planning is important but like put
planning aside punch fear in the face
and press record take action that's
where and motivation follows it's kind
of like floss one tooth I think in the
book tiny habits they talk about well I
don't want to floss I get my teeth
cleaned and I'm always super terrified
because the hygienist is gonna be like
so have you been flossing and you're
like well I haven't but you do like the
night before why are your gums all
swollen and like bleeding you're like
well I floss last night because I
thought it would make up for not
flossing for like and so in tiny half
habits they say instead of thinking oh
I'm just gonna I'm gonna develop the
habit of flossing every night make the
commitment to floss one tooth every
night well that's ridiculous exactly the
thing is though if you get the floss out
and you wrap around your fingers and you
floss one tooth why would you stop you
go met my action goal the momentum of
like well if I'm this far I might as
well finish the rest so it's the
momentum of not overthinking and just
getting to work and pressing record
number four create a routine for getting
in the zone this is a big one so you're
saying when your motivation's low you're
trying to think man how do I stay
motivated growth feels slow it's not in
the mood so how do I get into the Zone
how do I get into the mood I like to
pursue Flow State and if you never
studied Flow State perhaps we could talk
about it in the future it's a very it's
actually pretty well researched Flow
State you've probably been in it before
have you ever been creating content or
planning videos or scripting your videos
and time just flew by and you felt like
you were at your best and it was the
intersection of like distractions melted
away your energy was right in that sweet
spot it felt like your brain was firing
the ideas were flowing and everything
was just happening versus it's like
fingernails on Chalk you're like I'm
filming it's not smooth the ideas are
not flowing the ideas are not connecting
well the question is how do we get into
Flow State how do we stay into Flow
State how do we get in the zone and I
want to challenge you what are three
things you could stack together to spark
your motivation when your motivation is
low here's some things that I do if my
motivation is low which let me encourage
you it may seem like you know Sean the
think media team man they just don't
have bad days I can assure you the
opposite is true like the majority of
days I wake up and I'm like why I'm
turning 40 this year like my why does my
back hurt like what why am I exhausted
I've done everything right like I went
to bed at a good time what is growing on
my back you know the other night my wife
was like hey oh we're actually we're
gonna get massages very needed because
I'm turning 40. uh and she's like hey do
you want me to shave your back my wife
Sonia and I was like that's it yeah
that'd be great and she was like I just
thought that for the masseuse like it'd
be a lot better for their sake is what
she told me after and so she grabbed
this little electric razor and I didn't
realize how much back hair from so many
different places this back hair was
growing what's the point I have no idea
but the point is create a routine to get
in the zone so I like to stack these
things the point is motivation is hard
to come by and it's hard for me so I've
developed a stack of things I can do to
get me into the Zone when I'm not in the
zone
can you go for a walk or a run can you
cut unhealthy food meaning like I'm not
in the zone I'm just cutting it I'm like
I'm going to know I'll be in the zone in
the next 24 to 48 hours if I just start
eating healthy right now and that's not
even like one meal it's like I'm gonna
compound a couple days of eating healthy
can you get hydrated as you're literally
listening to this it's some time to
drink some water keep drinking water
drink some more water you're probably
dehydrated it's something like 93 of all
people are chronically dehydrated you
probably should drink some water you
will have better energy that's none of
this stuff is instant it's a stack that
has you compound it though by the
afternoon your whole outlook might
change but certainly in the next 48
hours you could be a whole new person
get some vitamin D if the sun's not out
you could supplement vitamin D plus K
get some great sleep read or listen to
content that changes charges you up turn
on a YouTube video turn on an audio book
read or listen to content that charges
you up turn off empty calorie content
turn off the shouting and turn out all
turn off the argue wing and turn off all
the vitriol and all the politics and all
the different stuff if you're into that
stuff that's fine but if your motivation
is low a lot of toxic energy and just
charged angry divisive debates I get it
that stuff could be necessary but is it
necessary for you right now especially
when you're not in a good headspace
especially when you maybe are trying
having trouble getting motivated turn it
off turn off empty calorie content pray
and then imagine if you did all these
things imagine if you stack them all so
what are three things you could stack
together to spark your motivation here's
one cool thing that uh I came up with
called a water walk
and especially when I'm in Vegas I can
walk out of our house and our
neighborhood and I can go on a short
loop around the block and it's not a
very long walk it might take like eight
minutes there's a version of it I could
do it multiple times or if I like carve
the edges of the neighborhood not just
the one block I could make it longer but
if I go on one water walk it's about
eight to ten minutes and it's three
things go for a walk bring water sip on
it as you're going or electrolytes uh no
sugar electrolytes amazon.com and bring
some Bluetooth headphones and listen to
some content that will reframe your
thinking and stack those three things
even for 10 minutes try it perhaps right
now that's what we're doing maybe I'm on
your water walk right now and you're
like dang I wish I would have brought
water and so I have found that I have
forget to drink water all day I've been
sitting at a computer all day I'm
starting to get tired fatigued and I
know that this is just kind of an energy
charge and a mindset reset but this is
part of it that to to start building
momentum to tackle your YouTube The
Challenge of getting motivated and
coming up with ideas Stacks some of
these things up right now I'm listening
to the wisdom of the bullfrog leadership
made simple but not easy by Admiral
William H mcraven who served 37 years as
an ABCO leadership content just
challenging content challenging me to be
like listen success is sometimes simple
but it's not easy it's like what to do
is kind of clear if I think about what
my next step should be I just don't feel
like doing it well that's what leaders
do leaders do it when they don't feel
like it so I'm listening to that the
other day as I'm stacking up some of
these things of my getting in the zone
routine and it's putting me into a whole
different set how headspace instead of
just opening up Instagram and seeing
what random reels come my way I
perfectly I intentionally picked an
audiobook
put on some Bluetooth headphones
and got back in the zone and then number
five remember why you started so if you
want to stay motivated when growth is
slow number one don't compare your
growth to others number two reframe your
perspective number three stop
overthinking and start working number
four create a routine for getting in the
zone and number five remember why you
started long time listeners of the think
media podcast and our VRA fam know that
we always say reasons come first results
come second the root word of motivation
is motive
so what is your motive for starting
YouTube in the first place is it to help
others you know if you're measuring
growth
and it is to help others think about the
subscribers and the views you've already
gotten has anyone left a positive
comment thanking you for your content
maybe your goal is to reach millions of
people or billions of people but
celebrate the one that you've encouraged
or that you've helped celebrate the ten
that you've been a moment of inspiration
or a moment of education for did you
start to express your creativity
are you creating content to capture
history and Legacy
why do why do you want to do YouTube
what is your motive for doing YouTube
and remember your why when motivation is
low to keep fighting for that goal even
if you're not experienced experiencing
growth you want to rekindle your passion
ask why are you excited about this why
were you excited about this in the first
place how can you discover and
ReDiscover your love for just content
creation period whatever happened to the
days when we just made videos for the
love of making videos whatever happened
to the days when it wasn't all about
just money or algorithms or views or
trying to beat your prior best or be a
one out of ten on YouTube and I'm
obsessed with all those things but I
definitely think I'm in a conversation
like this could be so healthy to just
kind of come back to the why can we just
inject more fun into the process of
creating content can we just create
because we were created in the we were
created by God in the image of our
creator to create just like he did and
just ex the act of creativity just the
art of it just the process of it and how
we're being change and how we're being
transformed I found that thoughts like
this they just help me get passionate
again so remember reasons come first
results come second and a few
recommended resources for you if you
that are my favorite resources for when
my motivation is low is uh one show your
work by Austin Cleon 10 ways to share
your creativity and get discovered two
do the work by Stephen pressfield
overcome resistance and get out of your
own way those are two books if they're
on audiobook I'd recommend it do the
work for a lot of artists and creatives
and entrepreneurs is a yearly read if
not a quarterly read do the work talks
about the resistance that you're
probably feeling and it's a short book
it's great and then if you want to check
out the wisdom of the bullfrog as well
um great for leaders I think everybody
would benefit from it again written by a
Navy Seal of 37 years Admiral mcraven
it's really good um I think he wrote a
book called make your bed or whatever
that's also very famous we'll link these
recommended resources in the show notes
in the YouTube description and my name
is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel I want to thank you for being a
part of the think media podcast and I
can't wait to connect with you in a
future episode